[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue faut-il fallait-il
autorisé l'installation d'une école
musulmane hors contrat à albertville en
savoie
c'est la question qu'on pose sur twitter
c'est la question également troupeau sur
youtube et les réponses suivant les
réseaux sont contradictoires alors en
débattre ce soir avec vous et on va
débattre de cela avec alexandre ii
vecchio bonsoir alexandre le journaliste
au service débat opinion du figaro en
charge des pages débats du figaro
magazine est en charge de figaro vox
avec vous avec nous
ce soir nicolas baverez comme chaque
lundi une semaine sur deux auteurs
dernièrement de la laërt démocratique
est aussi chroniqueur au figaro nicolas
vous avez d'ailleurs aborder un petit
peu indirectement la question
aujourd'hui puisque vous revenez
aujourd'hui sur l'humiliation infligée
par erdogan contre les européens la
semaine dernière à ankara alors l'autre
question qui vous taraude nicolas depuis
longtemps c'est le déclin français
c'était le sens de votre premier livre
en tout cas celui qui vous a fait
connaître sur la scène éditoriale et
médiatique en 2002 2003 2003 2003 déjà
c'était la france qui tombe quels sont
les symptômes comment stopper ce déclin
peut-on le stopper on en débat mais
d'abord donc cette question fallait-il
autorisé l'installation d'une école
privée musulmane à albertville questions
qu'on pose sur twitter qu'elle sont
campés sur youtube aussi on connaît la
réponse des magistrats c'est celle que
vous faites majoritairement sur twitter
en ce moment c'est oui et on connaît la
réponse du préfet ça c'est la réponse
que vous faites majoritairement sur
youtube
là c'est non le préfet de savoie
d'ailleurs vole au secours du maire de
la sous-préfecture savoyarde l'édile ans
l' alerte depuis des jours contre cette
initiative
voici ses arguments notre population aux
scolaires aujourd'hui elle est de 1600
élèves sur leurs structures élémentaires
400 élèves c'est un quart donc forcément
la création de cette école fermera des
classes voire des écoles potentiellement
une école c'est là où est le problème
c'était une école privée s'installerait
aux dépens d'une école républicaine
laïque pour albertville en tous les cas
déstabiliserait complètement le tissu
d'éducation de la ville
alors ne dites surtout pas qu'il s'agit
d'une école coranique il s'agit d'une
école musulmane privé hors contrat c'est
en ces termes en tous les cas que la
présente l'association qui doit la gérer
c'est la même que celle qui gère la
mosquée de strasbourg voici les
arguments à la réponse du responsable
local
donc de l'association me ligue au russe
le tribunal nous a donné raison les
musulmans de france on a le droit de
faire ministre comme tous les citoyens
ja rien d'islam il n'ya pas d'islamisme
c'est une colle comme les autres elle
est financée comment cette école à ses
financés par les fidèles dans toutes les
mosquées en france en europe 0 qui vient
de la turquie aux autres pays
cette précision parce que l'association
elle est d'origine turque elle a été
fondée par le mentor d'erdogan l'ancien
premier ministre necmettin erbakan qui a
été premier ministre turc et qui a été
renversé par les militaires de fin des
années 90 voici enfin le point de vue de
la ministre déléguée à la citoyenneté
marlène schiappa ce matin invité sur
europe 1 oui c'est un vrai problème
juridique notamment ce qui concerne le
délivrance des permis de construire est
donc là aussi le tribunal administratif
doit se prononcer ou va se prononcer le
projet de loi contre les séparatistes va
nous outiller et va nous permettre mais
mieux âgées pas rétroactif
non c'est pas rétroactif mais c'est
justement parce qu'il y avait des trous
dans la raquette que nous agissons plus
fermement sur ces questions
nicolas j'ai bien lu votre charge contre
les régimes d'erdogan dans votre
dernière chronique di figaro et on va
demander à vincent le noble de la mettre
dans le chatt justement sur le site du
figaro à côté du player mais vous qui
êtes libérale attachée à l'état de droit
biographe de tocqueville
vous êtes également attaché aux
décisions de justice à la liberté
individuelle
quel est votre point de vue je sais pas
la pression la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement la loi doit être la
même pour tous et qu'on soit musulmans
catholiques juifs orthodoxes et par
ailleurs la loi et les tribunaux sont là
pour appliquer sont là pour appliquer la
loi
je pense que le néanmoins le problème
que soulève le maire d'albertville était
éteint est un problème qui est tout à
fait fondée pourquoi parce que on voit
très bien que la réponse qui a été
apportée sur le financement est une
réponse extrêmement flou quand le
promoteur de cette école nous explique
que les fonds vont venir des fidèles en
france et en europe
en ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça
veut dire que cette école est en réalité
financé par un état étranger qui est la
turquie
ils s'en défendent oui mais les
financements d'europe
ça veut dire que très clairement je ne
vois pas trop pourquoi les musulmans
d'autres pays de reviendrait donc très
franchement on sait que dans la
stratégie de stabilisation de l'euro
vous croyez part à la turquie que dont
il ya le fait de financer un certain
nombre de réseaux d'associations
il ya des associations purement
religieuse
il ya tout un système d'institutions
scolaires et éducatives
et puis il y avait des association ultra
nationaliste du type les loups gris qui
ont été dissous donc c'est vrai que
depuis très longtemps il ya eu une
tolérance à tout niveau politique
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre
d'organisations islamiques et parfois
même islamistes ces compromis ont été
passées aux niveaux locaux mais il y
avait aussi
on promit nationale puisque pendant très
longtemps la république française a
trouvé très bien que la communauté
musulmane soit en réalité organisé
contrôlé par la turquie le maroc et
l'algérie des états qui d'ailleurs
rivaliser pour avoir le contrôle de
cette population
ça aujourd'hui ça n'est plus possible
compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé et de
la montée du terrorisme et la montée de
la montée du djihad et donc et donc il
faut en sortir
donc ça suppose que les magistrats fasse
preuve d'un peu de discernement mais ça
suppose surtout que les politiques
prennent leurs responsabilités puisque
j'y reviens quand vous regardez les
affaires du voile il faut quand même
toujours se rappeler que certes elles
sont parties de de créteil avec certes
une décision du conseil d'état qui sont
des laver les mains comme ponce pilate
mais pourquoi parce que le premier
ministre de l'époque était lionel jospin
mais suit le regard au moment de la
faire non non non c'était non mais
jamais lionel jospin et émilie dely
lucas les muses de l'éducation nationale
et michel rocard était pas voilà le il
lionel jospin ministre de l'éducation
effectivement de michel rocard a décidé
de demander l'avis du conseil d'état
mais personne n'a pris ses
responsabilités et l'ajustement le maire
prend le maire s'oppose absolument à
l'établissement de cette mosquée est
cette association a porté plainte devant
la justice administrative devant le
tribunal admistratif de grenoble et le
tribunal administratif de grenoble a
rejeté le refus d'accorder un permis de
construire à cette voie à d'autres il va
y avoir un appel et il est il
souhaitable que on appelle
on tienne un peu compte de l'ensemble du
dossier alors alexandre moi je compose
un peu la même question que cani collage
que je connais votre donc si je suis par
contre pendant nicolas je termine avec
vous a priori vous êtes-vous dit la loi
est la même pour tous mais là ça demande
un discernement particulier qui devrait
non prenons l'exemple de des écoles
catholiques des écoles catholiques ne
sont pas financés par le vatican qui est
un état des écoles catholiques sont
financées par les familles et les
familles utilisent ces écoles et puis
son compte si elles sont sous contrat
elles sont si elles sont hors contrat
c'est uniquement les familles si elles
sont sous contrat par ailleurs les
professeurs sont payés par l'éducation
nationale
donc il ya un cadre clair mais il n'y a
pas d'état étranger derrière le
financement de des écoles des écoles
catholiques aujourd'hui
or justement c'est à la question je
voulais vous poser un peu alexandre
puisque je connais votre attachement la
public à l'identité mais aussi aux
libertés une école religieuse hors
contrat ça existe en france en réalité
que ça pose des problèmes d'ordre public
ou d'attachement oui c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai un désaccord avec nicolas
bellrays la loi je suis désolé ne peut
pas être la même pour tous à état de
guerre on l'a assez dit l' état
d'exception je pense que la loi sur la
séparation de le séparatisme a raté son
objet ça aurait dû être une loi contre
le séparatisme islamistes viser
précisément l'ennemi ce qu'elle ne fait
pas elle nous laisse démunis au
contraire à elle vise indifféremment
tout le monde ce qui fait qu'elle
pénalise des gens qui sont respectueux
de la loi et des valeurs de la
république je pense à ce qu'ils font aux
catholiques qui font l'école à la maison
et c'est donc je pense qu'il aurait
fallu cible est effectivement en une
idéologie contraire qui met en danger
clairement la sécurité la sécurité
nationale parce que c'est vrai que alors
on peut s'appuyer dire les financements
étrangers comme le dit nicolas baverez
il faut avoir un juge qui fait preuve de
discernement et avec les phénomènes de
est ce que le démocrate démographique il
ya dans certains quartiers je rappelle
que l'école qui va être construite c'est
pour 400 élèves un cas des enfants de la
ville c'est dire le poids démographique
de certaines populations
et bien voilà la question se posera
financement étranger ou pas financement
étranger donc vous faut dire clairement
quelle est l'idéologie qui est sont
rentrés dans la liberté de pensée mais à
partir du moment où ça met clairement en
danger la sécurité nationale je pense
qu'il fallait cesser l'hypocrisie et que
cette loi qui va ne pas servir à grand
chose c'est réellement à quelque chose
ensuite deuxième hypocrisie je pense que
pour éviter ce genre de dérive à
l'avenir il va falloir être beaucoup
plus de jours sur la politique
migratoire je le répète c'est 400 élèves
un quart de la ville alors sans doute
beaucoup on a la nationalité française
est ce que dit instable et quand est ce
que dit le responsable local mais si on
ajoute encore des flux à cette situation
de ghettos puisque la pourrait y avoir
une école en réalité pour les turcs dans
cette ville avec une véritable volonté
de ses parts à thiais je rappelle que
erdogan estime que l'assimilation est un
crime contre l'humanité et qu'il en
jouant les populations turques qui
vivent enfin d'origine turque qui vivent
en europe à ne pas à ne pas assimiler
donc là on a un cas typique de
séparatistes si on ajoute encore des
flux à ce problème là on ne fera
qu'aggraver le problème donc il faut
être vraiment rigoureux désormais dans
la politique migratoire et ce pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas la nationalité
française et qui ne me nine
manifesterait pas la volonté de
respecter les lois de la république de
s'intégrer ou qui auraient un discours
clairement séparatiste eh bien il faut
leur signaler qu'ils ne peuvent pas
enfin il faut les prendre des mesures
d'expulsion sur le fait et je peux pas
être la même pour tous avec les
arguments de mais on avance dans
meilleur en fait on est assez d'accord
sur le projet et ce qui a été dit mais
en revanche je pense que le
utilisation du de la rhétorique
guerrière est complètement déplacé que
c'est une énorme erreur
on a vu que ce que ça donnait quand on
utilisait la guerre contre l'épidémie et
la guerre contre le terrorisme
utilisé de manière débridée ça a donné
les dérives de la politique américaine
un terrible échec intérieur et extérieur
donc il faut être clair la france n'est
certainement pas en guerre contre
l'islam ne ne sommes pas en guerre
contre les me permet de le dire pour le
préciser parce que je normal rapidement
il faut être clair sur les que les 400
élèves et familles concernées
d'albertville il ya sûrement pas 400
islamistes mais mais or donc il faut pas
utiliser ce terme de game ne serait ce
que parce que ils appellent à une autre
dérive derrière qui est l'utilisation de
l'armé pour faire de sécurité intérieure
et ça sauf si on arrivait un stade
extrême
il faut l'éviter donc je ne crois pas à
cette métaphore guerrière je crois qu'il
est très important que la loi soit la
même pour tous parce que nous nous
pouvons lutter contre le fanatisme
islamiste précisément qu au nom des
valeurs démocratiques et en montrant
qu'elle fonctionne
y compris en matière de sécurité mais et
est donc c'est bien pour ça que la loi
doit être la même pour tous les il faut
être bien clair les musulmans qu'ils
soient citoyens français où qu'ils
soient étrangers en situation régulière
et respectant la loi de la république
c'est tous ces gens là sont couverts par
les mêmes mois que nous les mêmes mois
ont vocation à s'appliquer à eux comme à
nous non mais l'athlète chez eux on est
on est d'accord et évidemment je ne
parlais pas de loi spécifique pour les
musulmans mais à menace spécifique qui
pose des problèmes spécifiques qui se
sert parfois des la démocratie pour
mieux la combattre
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas cibler
ne pas assumer une politique
d'assimilation alors je sais pas si la
métaphore guerrière à la bonne c'était
celle de de manuel valls mais en tout
cas il faut arrêter
deux sont retranchés derrière la laïcité
le fanatisme en général puisque on est
face à un fanatisme particulier alain
qui nous dit une question qui dont je
pense qu'elle appellera une réaction de
votre part nicolas contre l'islamisme la
démocratie et des armées je crois pas
qu'elle soit désarmé parce que on l'a vu
en fait dans beaucoup de pays elle
arrive elle arrive à tenir mais si vous
voulez elle est désarmée de deux
manières soit si effectivement elle
renonce à défendre ce qu'elle est et
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
renoncement soit signal inverse
elle abandonne ses valeurs et qu'elle se
met à part ce que a refusé les libertés
aux ennemis de la liberté et à ce moment
là elle se comporte effectivement comme
ses ennemis et c'est entre ces deux
extrêmes qui faut arriver à tracer des
politiques raisonnables mais on constate
que dans le monde il ya des démocraties
où on arrivait à la fois à intégrer tout
à fait y compris des communautés
ullman à réprimer évidemment la
délinquance ou le terrorisme et avoir un
état de droit qui fonctionne de manière
de manière satisfaisante donc c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas gravé dans le marbre il
peut s'adapter en fonction des
circonstances et à droite c'est aussi la
loi quand on vote on peut faire voter
une loi spécifique qui s'attaque
réellement aux menaces ensuite vous
allez dis quelque chose qui me paraît
intéressant et pertinent vous avez dit
les 400 élèves qui vont aller dans cette
école ne sont pas de famille islamistes
je partage votre point de vue mais je
m'interroge quand même pourquoi il y
aurait un quart de la population de la
ville qui déserteraient sous d'helmand
l'école de la république pour aller dans
une école qui est clairement identifié
six sna islamistes islamo-nationaliste
puisque c'est la mouvance er but
ghanéenne ça montre bien que
l'intégration ne fonctionne pas et qu'
il ya une partie de la population qui
parfois même la nationalité française
qui refuse finalement de s'intégrer de
s'assimiler donc peut-être qu'il faut
pas utilisé une rhétorique guerrière
mais il faut utiliser une rhétorique
clair leur dire clairement ce que l'on
veut et pense que la bonne politique à
mener et de dire nous acceptons
effectivement toutes les populations
étrangères mais c'est elle qui veulent
s'intégrer s'assimiler même pas ce que
je sais c'est pas un gros mot mais mais
celles qui ne le souhaitent pas n'ont
pas vocation à rester sur le territoire
non mais sur le caractère déraisonnable
et démesurée de ce projet et son
caractère inacceptable on est on est
parfaitement on est parfaitement
d'accord alors je vous propose justement
de donner la parole à nos internautes je
salue au passage
nicole à la con un site tout à l'heure
christian léon bonsoir et également ceux
qui utilisent des pseudos comme avec
respect je vous soumets deux
commentaires d'abord de commentaires qui
met de youtube celui de kério d'eau qui
nous dit une loi contre le séparatisme a
été votée il ya moins de 15 jours
et là on parle d'école religieuse
l'école doit être laïque après rien
n'interdit de prendre des cours de
religion dans la sphère privée
est ce que finalement le risque de
toutes ces polémiques
ce n'est pas ça que ce que sous-entend
caruso c'est que finalement on aura plus
d'écoles religieuses et on va être tous
à l'école laïque
oui mais je pense que ce serait une
mauvaise solution je suis plutôt laïque
plutôt attaché à l'école publique même
si elle a vraiment perdu de sa superbe
ces dernières années mais pourquoi punir
des catholiques des juifs à des gens qui
respectent la loi des musulmans modérés
aussi qui peut par des voiles à des
musulmans qu'ils respectent les lois de
la peau de la république qui veulent
s'intégrer mais qu'ils veulent avoir une
pratique de leur culte
pourquoi punir tous ces gens là parce
que il ya des islamistes qu un autre
projet qui a un projet de conquête
politique idéologique
donc c'est pour ça que je dirais qu'il
faut effectivement cibler ce sera un
recul de punir tout le monde pour
combattre
quelques-uns comme essayent illustre
exactement ce que je
j'ai dit ça c'est évidemment le piège
qui est tendu par les islamistes
pourquoi parce que je rappelle qu'il ya
dans l'état de droit une grande liberté
qui est la liberté de l'enseignement et
qu'elle est aussi importante que la
liberté de pensée ou que la liberté
d'expression et de la liberté
d'enseignement c'est que par ailleurs il
faut être clair l'enseignement religieux
n'a rien de
de d'illégitime dans une démocratie et
il est tout à fait normal que il fait
partie des possibilités qui doivent être
offertes aux familles et aux citoyens
d'un pays est ensuite libre à eux de
choisir simplement des établissements y
compris des établissements
confessionnels ce ne sont pas des
établissements qui sont contrôlés par
une puissance étrangère
c'est pas possible pour éviter ce genre
de dérive nous dit également
redouane il faut arrêter de diaboliser
la religion et s'attaquer au problème de
foire je sais pas ce que vous entendez
exactement par sa red one mais c'est
intéressant ce que ça nous offre une
place d'une transition avec le deuxième
tome juste rapidement l'état de droit
c'est important mais on a vu récemment
que la loi séparatistes pouvait
s'appliquer dans des conditions je pense
que d'accord totalement limites
quoi qu'on en pense de l'idéologie de
génération identitaire mois où certains
aspects de leur idéologie me gêne mais
enfin on ne se sont pas des gens qui
menaçaient la sécurité intérieure et on
a pu les 10 août donc simplement pour
dire que la l'état de droit ne doit pas
s'appliquer de poids de menus de avec
deux poids deux mesures et surtout pas
ne s'appliquait sur des fausses menaces
finalement en ignorant et en se
soumettant à de vraies menaces la
question de quand vous posez à la fois
sur youtube et sur twitter
c'était fallait-il autorisé
l'installation d'une école privée
musulmane albertville alors sachant que
là
la question reste reste opposée puisque
en première instance un tribunal
administratif de grenoble donc a annulé
le refus de permis de construire mais
vraisemblablement en tous les cas on
peut le penser puisque le préfet a
demandé à ce qu'ils aient un appel qui
soit interjeté par rapport à 7 à cette
décision donc on suit continuera de
suivre cette question alors oui 76% sur
twitter et c'était non à 80% sur youtube
vous continuez de voter vous choisissez
votre plateforme bien entendu l'autre
question qu'on pose ce soir c'est pensez
vous que l'on peut stopper le déclin
français alors on a la chance d'avoir un
plateau ce soir l'un des hommes qui a
fait beaucoup couler d'encre sur cette
question puisque il a été à l'origine on
peut le dire d'une notion qu'on a
beaucoup entendu parler en son temps
c'est la décline au logis merci nicolas
bresse d'être d'être ici alors on va
voir d'abord s'il est possible de
stopper le déclin français
je vous propose d'écouter en tous les
cas un homme qui le dénoncent et dénonce
un de ses responsables selon lui c'est
emmanuel macron le responsable cet homme
qui accuse le président de la république
c'est philippe de villiers deux choses
il a laissé se déchirer les tissus
conjonctifs de la france industrielle
la start-up nationale et un ehpad et il
a laissé se dressait sonia mabrouk un
mur invisible entre deux sociétés la
société française et une contre-société
vindicative qui est en train de nous
coloniser vous
la start up nation française est en
ehpad dit philippe de villiers quand il
sortit la fin je voyais sourire vous
partager son diagnostic
enfin le diagnostic je crois que
maintenant il est bien établi c'est vrai
que la décline au logis c'est une
science absurde où on serait heureux du
déclin et on ne penserait fatale et on
serait heureux d'y participer
c'est ce long temps vous que je les
partis à la chasse aux phoques aussi
voulait la france qui tombe ça date de
2003 aujourd'hui on est presque 20 ans
après la france n'a cessé de descendre
les marches au fil des chocs et et des
crises et le déclin j'allais dire
aujourd'hui c'est plus un objet de débat
d'ailleurs plus personne ne me traite de
déclinistes parce que c'est tellement
évident et surtout l'intérêt malheureux
de cette épidémie
c'est que les français en ont vraiment
pris la mesure c'est à dire que là
chaque français a vu ce que c'était
d'avoir un état qui ne marchait plus un
système de santé dont ont expliqué
qu'ils étaient meilleurs du monde et qui
s'est réveillée qui a failli pas de la
faute des soignants et des politiques
conduites sur les masques les tests les
ventilateurs l'hydre animations
maintenant la vaccination
on a vu ce que c'était de plus avoir
d'industrie on a vu ce que c'était de
plus avoir de recherche donc tout le
monde attendait les vaccins sanofi
pasteur on les protège et d'ailleurs
pour être sûr et en fait on s'est aperçu
que il n'y a pas de vaccins sanofi a pas
de vaccin pasteur et pour une bonne
raison c'est que les chercheurs qui
trouvent comme emmanuel charpentier ils
sont à l'étranger
les chercheurs qui cherchent mais qui ne
trouve rien ou qui ne trouvent plus
parce qu'ils sont à la fois prolétarisés
et dans un monstre bureaucratique qui
les broie et bien c'est chez nous donc
maintenant si vous voulez il n'ya plus
tellement de questions sur le constat ce
qui est ce que vous croyez à blement
grave c'est qu'on on n'en parle pas on
n'en débat pas est qu on n'est plus dans
la haie et qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez
la proche de l'édition de 2022
seul thème qui devrait être partagé par
tous et comme on s'en sort comment on se
remet dans la position de 45 c'est à
dire avec un pays qui est maintenant un
pays en ruine et déclassé et comment on
leur construit c'est ça le seul vrai
débat mais alors justement on va on va
l'aborder donc du coup ça chez nous gré
en tous les cas de le faire est de
l'organiser ce soir alexandre est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec nicolas sur le
sur le diagnostic qui est posée oui je
peux parce qu'on a eu un jour 40
sanitaire ça semble quand même à
l'étrange défaite de marc bloch
même si évidemment la france est pas
occupé la situation par certains aspects
et est moins dramatique mais je rejoins
tout à fait cette comparaison est ce
diagnostic je crois que le bateau prend
l'eau
un peu partout qu'il ya trois pros
priorité désormais c'est celle de
rebâtir l'état je crois que vouloir
faire disparaître l'état ce soir est une
erreur on a vu les défaillances de
l'état bureaucratique mais le besoin
d'un état stratège d'un état fort s'est
fait ressentir le bateau prend l'eau
aussi sur le déficit commercial
là on en a pris conscience qu'on a vu
qu'on était dépendant à l'égard de la
chine dans tout ce qui était production
industrielle dont il est urgent de
réindustrialiser et troisième point il
ya le point qu'on évoquait en première
partie la question de la partition de
l'archipel isation du territoire et là
encore on va avoir besoin d'unité et
cette unité on l'obtiendra je crois par
le dépassement justement définissant ce
que doit être la france notre culture
mais aussi notre projet d'avenir alors
avant de
il me semble que vous êtes d'accord sur
ces trois sur ses trois associés qui me
surprit en vous disant justement
nicolas il ya peut-être une chose sur
laquelle vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous
me confirmer pour vous nicolas le déclin
de la france n'est ni du au capitalisme
mondialisé ni à la construction
européenne
non il est avant tout dû à nos erreurs
puisque c'est un des points sur lesquels
je pense que le philippe de villiers se
trompe c'est que emmanuel macron a
clairement aggravé les choses
mais c'est pas lui qui est à l'origine
d'une certaine manière il est né en même
temps que le décrochage français enfin
peu après mais enfin à peu prend
maintenant puisque c'est vers la fin des
années 70 et l'incapacité on n'a pas su
s'adapter
d'abord au monde post keynésien
l'arrivée de la mondialisation la chute
du mur de berlin la réunification de
l'europe le passage à l'euro
on est passés à côté de toutes ces
marches en laissant en place en partie
avec le grand choix ça a été 83 où on a
laissé une partie de l'économie privée
s'adapter au monde ouvert et où on a
sanctuarisé un énorme secteur public
avec des règles qui sont restés celle
des années 70 et au départ ça a permis
de tenir encore un peu et maintenant
c'est devenu complètement incompatible
et on a ce pays effectivement ensuite un
pays qui est complètement déchiré entre
une partie de la france qui fait à peu
près 15 20 % du total qui est
compétitive mais qui est tourné vers
l'étranger est de plus en plus offshore
et puis le reste qui vit en réalité soit
dans des secteurs protégés plus blé soit
dans la ville gigantesque secteur public
et qui vit uniquement de la dette
publique qui est passée de 20% du pib'
en 1980 à 120% du pib aujourd'hui et qui
ne peut plus augmenter donc on est un
peu si vous voulez une grosse italie et
maintenant avec effectivement des pôles
d'excellence qui restent mais qu'ils
sont petits et un système politique
sociale et économique qui est en train
de se déchirer et de se déliter donc
nous sommes un pays du sud un pays
surendetté sous compétitif
effectivement avec une société de plus à
ce questionnement le problème le plus
complexe une société passe en plus des
chirurgies réalisées
alexandre avant de revenir sur peut-être
sur ce que dit nicolas sur cette société
sur cette économie à deux vitesses quand
nicolas voulzy dit que l'éclat la france
n'est ni du au capitalisme mondialisé ni
à la construction européenne
d'accord non je pense qu'on a eu nos
faiblesses propres
on est peut-être l'un des pays les plus
affaiblis en europe plus que l'allemagne
mais je compte a constaté la crise
sanitaire on l'a bien montré
c'est toute la zone euro qui est
affaiblie et qui en déclin donc je pense
que malgré tout l'économie ouverte
l'union européenne un papa l'europe pour
accentuer finalement les faiblesses de
la france sur la question du déficit
commercial
une politique du libre-échange naïf face
à la chine a été accentuée quand même
par la volonté la volonté européenne sur
le plomb justement de la société
fractionnez l'idée européenne que
finalement l'identité de chaque peuple
européen ne comptait pas qu'il fallait
maintenant avoir une europe
multiculturelle que l'immigré à la
question de l'immigration on devait pas
la limite et finalement elle a les mêmes
résoudre nos problèmes de déficits
publics tout ça ça a aggravé tout de
même les difficultés de la france et je
suis d'accord sans doute que il ya un
niveau de dépense publique qui est une
partie de la population qui est sous
perfusion mais je pense que les
désordres et les dérèglements un liés à
la mondialisation ont accentué ce besoin
d'un état social qui finalement vient
passer la serpillière sociale mais une
fois qu'on a déséquilibré totalement la
société et l'économie
ils nous respectent allemand de temps je
suis désolé mans continuera ce débat
mais peut-être
vous voulez les remèdes que vous
préconisez aujourd'hui
nicolas il ya d'abord vous dit peut-être
pas d'abord il ya plein de choses que
vous préconisez mais notamment vous
pensez qu'il faut plus de centralisation
et moins de pouvoirs au président je
crois qu'il ya deux choses pour aller
vite ya un problème de méthode et puis
ensuite les axes qui sont d'ailleurs pas
très éloignés de ceux évoqués par
alexandre et vecchio donc la méthode
c'est que je pense effectivement que
précisément il faut arrêter de chercher
des boucs émissaires la mondialisation
et c'est donc la première chose c'est
que il n'ya que les français qui peuvent
remettre la france d'aplomb donc
arrêtons de chercher des boucs
émissaires et mettons-nous et traitons
de problème c'est pas l'europe mais la
mondialisation qui a fait la loi des 35
heures donc où toute une série d'autres
choses complètement absurde c'est pas
eux qui ont mis les dépenses de l'état
providence à 34%
c'est pas eux qui ont ils font dre le la
santé l'éducation ou la sécurité en
partie fait donc
et la deuxième chose qui est très
importante c'est qu'il faut arrêter de
détection au monde pour l'instant il
faut remettre le pays d'aplomb un peu ce
que l'ine byden c'est à dire une fois
qu'on aura remis la maison france en
ordre on ira expliquer aux libanais
comment est-ce qu'il faut qu'il reste
leur état ou telle idée trouve pas ça
c'est la méthode
ensuite si on applique ça on a quatre
grands thèmes le premier mot très
important c'est la production la france
ne produit plus et ça et c'est vrai
aussi pour le secteur public parce que
vous voyez le la santé l'éducation la
sécurité intérieure qu'on oublie
toujours que c'est du service aux
citoyens et donc la première chose c'est
de s'occuper aussi dans le public de la
qualité du service
la deuxième chose c'est l'intégration ce
qui a été évoqué c'est à dire qu' il
faut une règle du jeu claire
effectivement y compris en matière de
d'immigration et le but c'est que
d'intégrer les gens d'intégrer la
jeunesse qui est exclu d'intégrer les
étrangers s'il ya des gens qui veulent
peu à s'intégrer effectivement c'est une
autre question
la troisième chose qui est extrêmement
importante c'est l'état on a l'état qui
ne marchent plus donc il faut le
remettre au service des citoyens c'est
un état qui fonctionne pour l'état est
ce qu'on a très bien vu pour la santé il
gère des protocoles pour lui même fait
il gère de la bureaucratie pour lui même
il ne rend plus de services aux citoyens
et donc il faut le recentrer sur le
régalien et sur le service aux citoyens
il a dépanné aujourd'hui de l'état
stratège d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas là
on est d'accord non on est bien d'accord
une des choses qui a manqué ce qu'on a
vu dans l'épidémie des choses qui a
manqué c'est l'anticipation mais les
allemands ont fait mieux les coréens les
taiwanais fait il ya beaucoup de pays
qui font mieux l'europe du nord a fait
mieux mais nous effectivement la
stratégie le moins qu'on puisse dire
on a été mauvais dans l'anticipation et
on a été très mauvais dans la stratégie
de l'histoire de l'europe du nord mais
parler de la gestion à la néerlandaise
ou de la gestion à la suédoise
non mais il ya différents cas si vous
voulez chaque pays a tâtonné mais au
bout de la barrière aux normes et au
bout du bout peu importe j'allais dire
la metteuse qui est important c'est de
regarder un an après qu'est ce qu'on a
comme nombre de morts qu'est ce qu'on a
comme taux de vaccination qu'est ce
qu'on a comme dégâts sur l'économie et
la société
ensuite chacun a fait ça mais c'est ça
qui compte et il y en a beaucoup moins
je ne pourrai donc endormi et la
dernière chose c'est la démocratie c'est
à dire que de fait on peut pas en rester
à la manière dont ça fonctionne et vous
voyez la manière d albertville est
intéressante parce qu'on explique
toujours qu'il ya quelques aces qui
sonne l'alerté relationnel de l'arbre en
l'occurrence alors on dirait que ce
n'est pas le cas à strasbourg
mais c'est le maire d'albertville et
l'état non seulement il
un essai faire mais on a même des
magistrats qui sont prêt à couvrir cette
décision absurde
donc la décentralisation fait partie des
remèdes mais aussi une limitation des
pouvoirs du président et notamment du
pouvoir de nomination qui est
complètement complètement absurde
président de la république ferait
beaucoup mieux de s'occuper de beaucoup
d'autres choses que de nommer tous les
directeurs de musées les responsables de
de toute une série de passer son temps à
faire des auditions pour les entreprises
publiques pour les musées pour les
théâtres pour les opéras et je ne sais
quoi
il ya suffisamment de problèmes pour
remettre la france d'aplomb ne sont pas
ceux là
vous parliez d'une belle d'albertville
une information le gouvernement
justement veut encadrer les ouvertures
d'écoles sous influence étrangère
il a déposé un amendement à la loi
séparatisme pour lutter contre les
ingérences étrangères par
l'intermédiaire d'ouverture des cols
hors contrat on est justement dans cette
danse est question avec l'école
d'albertville et c'est une info figaro
alexandre et potions du docteur ben vrai
ça vous paraît non mais on est on est
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses
revenons une minute sur le diagnostic
n'a pas tellement plus d'une minute
le diagnostic est un point de désaccord
sur la désindustrialisation je maintiens
que les choix qui ont été faits qui ont
été favorisées notamment pour l'europe
d'axer notre économie sur les services
et de désindustrialisé massivement se
sont se sont payés y compris par des
dépenses publiques qui sont devenues
nécessaires pour assister la population
qui se retrouvaient sur le chaos
ça c'est une chose autre petit point de
désaccord ou même vos points de
désaccord pour le coup je suis plus
dubitatif sur la décentralisation j'ai
l'impression qu'on nous explique que
c'est la solution à tout il se pourrait
très bien que ça amène à une
bureaucratie locale
je suis les ars c'est quand même un
mélange de lunel ont là on est un grand
parti dans la descente dans la
décentralisation qui s'entraîne oui il
essaie quand même l'idée
à chaque chacun à son agence régionale
etc effectivement vous l'avez dit
reconnue vous même le clientélisme à
l'échelle locale ça existe là
effectivement le maire d'albertville à
une réaction assez assez cède mais on
voit bien qu'à strasbourg c'est tout à
fait différent
pensez vous que l'on peut stopper le
déclin français c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter avant de regarder
les résultats
aladdin nous dit sur youtube youtube
jeudi j'ai dit oui car je suis optimiste
nature mais la seule condition c'est de
bien ouvrir les yeux sur ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment du mal à la france
christian le en nous dit déclin oui
parce que les oppositions profitent des
efforts de notre gouvernement pour nous
filer la frousse de tous j'ai envie
d'être optimiste et de dire oui nous dit
cet autre internaute sur youtube sanguin
je crois en la france et au peuple
français pour arrêter de nous diviser et
oeuvrait pour notre patrie cet autre
internaute qui ne donne pas son nom mais
qui nous dit les universités françaises
font de moins en moins rêver un elie sur
youtube il faut réindustrialiser la
france relancer l'ascenseur social en
donnant les moyens pour une école de
qualité var effectivement délices et
également les potions du docteur hubert
ezin ne veux pas parler en votre terme
mais je pense que c'était sur l'
ordonnance
il faut lutter contre la précarité et
permettre à tous l'accès à la culture
aux lieux culturels mais surtout
redonner l'envié de lire des livres
alors je vous recommande notamment ceux
d'alexandre et de nicolas et cet autre
internaute encore nous dit macron a
échoué je ne vois pas qui pourrait
réussir nos politiciens ne pense qu'aux
élections de marine à mélenchon et
nicolas baverez et alexandre de view
vous direz mais il faut faire confiance
aux français je vous citerai pour ma
part injustement une figure étrangères
qui s'appelait joseph désiré mercier qui
est belge et qui disait au dix neuvième
siècle
la france est une grande nation mais
pour le demeurer il faut qu'elle s'en
souvienne
eh bien je porte ce à votre méditation
et je vous donne rendez vous demain même
heure même endroit pour un nouveau
numéro de points de vue à très vite sur
fear alive
[Musique]